different
all right everyone welcome to the dtps
seminar today
um and people we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk and
please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q a session at the end second today is
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so watch out
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel
um okay that's about it let me introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
Uday Kumar who is a low cover professor
of mechanical engineering and Associate
dean of research graduate programs and
faculty in the College of Engineering at
the University of Iowa
he received a BT tag in aerospace
engineering from the Indian Institute of
Technology and Ms and PhD degrees from
the University of Florida
he has published over 150 Journal papers
in varied topic areas of biomedical and
mechanical engineering his research
focus is on multi-scale modeling and
simulation of a wide range of moving
boundary problems and Thermo mechanical
systems ranging from
phase change thermal stories biomedical
applications involving cardiovascular
and
gastroint intestine in intestinal
mechanics energetic material Dynamics
and proportions and Munitions and the
multi-phase Flows at all speeds it has
been supported by grants from NSF we
taker Foundation biomedical engineering
Grant and IET age and VA research grants
and multiple concurrent branches from
various DOD agencies today they will
present an exciting topic which is data
driven multi-scale simulations for
materials by design of energetic
materials please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk now without further Ado
let me pass the button today by asking
one random question as usual since it is
Friday in order to recommend a movie for
the weekend whoever wants to watch movie
this weekend today's random question is
what is your favorite movie today
I guess you didn't expect that no I
didn't expect that my favorite movie
um
my favorite movie would be
Apple Apollo 13. I think that's my
favorite movie because it's you know I
love Tom Hanks I love space and uh I
always show that movie to my students as
a great motivating movie for engineers
you know because that particular scene
when they Cobble together the device to
scrub the CO2 in the module
um you know is an excellent example of
Hands-On
um you know in Engineering in a very
very uh high pressure situation and of
course I I forced my daughters to watch
it as our Christmas movie which doesn't
go very well in our household but but
yeah that's my favorite movie thank you
for that question thank you thank you
for sharing it
um okay the stage is yours okay
thank you thank you young soup yeah
thanks for for inviting me uh you know
I've been to Livermore I was saying
earlier this year and it's uh great to
be returning uh back all the virtually
um I hope you can see my screen still
young soon yeah
okay great great
um so yeah so I was I'll be talking
today about data driven multi-scale
simulations for energetic materials um
this is work that is uh funded by
um the Air Force Murray program uh and
by there are parts of it that are NSF
dmref program Grant funded and also
parts of it from Aro uh and I do I do
want to mention that this is
collaborative work with Stephen Beck who
is actually the Deep learning person I'm
a collaborator on this um and fun who's
also a deep learning person working with
Steve back at Virginia
uh and we've been working on this for
for quite a while now I would say last
three or four years in the Murray
program uh so I'm gonna try to give a
you know I I was kind of deciding
whether to go deep or go abroad and I'd
settle for somewhere in the middle so it
might be you know not wholly satisfying
for everybody uh depending on what they
prefer but hopefully it'll give you a
sense for what what we have done so far
and and where we are heading with this
okay
Okay so
so I I don't know whether you know
everybody is familiar with energetic
materials I will assume uh there are
others who are not in energetic so I'll
give a very brief account of what we are
doing here uh so
experiments various types of experiments
show that energetic materials are uh are
very sensitive uh obviously and their
sensitivity depends uh on the
microstructure of the maternal so uh you
know for here is an example of a
sensitivity curve this particular one is
called a James curve on the x-axis is
What's called the power flux and the
y-axis is what's called Energy fluence
you can think of the x-axis as being the
pressure shock pressure and the y-axis
as being the shock pulse width or a
flyer thickness so typically these are
impact experiments with a flyer coming
in at a certain velocity so x-axis is
the shock pressure induced by the flyer
and the y-axis uh is the thickness of
the pulse uh and in this uh plane the
the curve separates above the curve is
critical in the sense that the explosive
or the energetic metal will will
detonate and below the curve it will not
detonate so it's the criticality curve
and you can see that for two different
microstructures class three and class 5
of hmx this is pressed hmx uh you can
see that the criticality envelopes are
very different that is you know the
material sensitivity is significantly
influenced by the microstructure in
particular it's influenced by the
porosity of the material you can see
that in those microstructures uh there
are all these cracks and pores and so on
and so the the prevalence of these sites
determines the the criticality curve for
these Metals so and this is not this is
the one experiment there are you know
scores of experiments that show various
dependencies on the microstructure so
this is the fundamental kind of
underlying feature of what we're going
to try to understand through our work uh
what we want to do is predictive models
for energetic materials and they are
inherently multi-scale because as I said
the the eventual fate of the the
explosiveness sensitivity and so on of
the material at the macro scale depends
on what's going on in the microstructure
which I shall call the measure scale for
the purpose of this talk
um and then of course what happens here
is determined by the molecular scale
properties of the material you know what
is its um strength in particular you
know how does it what is its equation of
state and other thermophysical
properties so there is a telescoping of
molecular scale properties on to measure
scale properties and then all the way to
match scale so we need to build all of
this connectivity across scales in order
to predictively stimulate what's going
to happen to an energetic material when
it's shock loaded and my talk is going
to be all about shock loading because
that's the regime of interest
at least in my work there are lots of
sub shock detonations and so on but we
won't be covering that that type of
event in the stock
so fundamentally the mechanism that
leads to sensitivity uh at the measure
scale is
um uh when you when you lower a shock
you form hot spots and these hot spots
typically localize and defects in the
methadone so this could be cracks or
pores or something
um there are many many mechanisms of hot
spots uh formation from these defects
but in the shock regime or high shock
regime when we're talking about you know
10 GPA Plus or even let's say 6 GPA plus
shock loading
um the primary uh cause of localization
is the collapse of pores so these pores
collapse uh
strength does matter but it's nearly a
hydrodynamic collapse and when they
collapse there is jetting and other form
other high-speed phenomena that happen
just like cavitation bubbles
um and you form a hot spot and the hot
spots then trigger reactions and then
the reaction front propagates and then
fills the material and that then you
know it's off to the races at that point
uh and if there is a coupling between
this reaction and the shock the shock
will then transition to a detonation and
then you get what is called Shock to
detonation transition and and you get uh
you know full full blow up or the metal
so that's the mechanism that we want to
capture uh now this has been for a very
very long time you know especially
exemplified by the by the phenomenal
work of uh Craig Tarver
um and others uh at Livermore and and
other labs as well uh typically these
these phenomena of the hotspot formation
and the mesoscale phenomena leading to
the macro scale
um detonation where typically inserted
into Hydro codes uh by using what are
called burn models or reactive burn
models uh there are many many flavors of
these uh and you know depending on on
what your speed is you can you can use
many of these which are well calibrated
for some particular formulations of
energetic materials
um but a common one or a popular one is
Craig Tarver and and others tarva
Nichols uh you know a lot of people that
deliver more contributing to this
um it's called the ignition and growth
model where there's an ignition rate
term uh that is pressure that is
dependent on the density and the
compressibility the material and the
great term uh growth rate term of hot
spots that is pressure dependent so this
is a semi-empirical model
phenomenological model where all these
parameters e x and so on are fit to
experiments and so there are lots of
experiments conducted for each
formulation and then you get these
models now these are the traditional
routes of empirical empirical burn
models uh what we mean by data driven
models is that we are going to use
simulations as opposed to physical
experiments to obtain the use ignition
growth rate parameters right so so this
is the building then is placed on how
well you can stimulate the phenomena and
there are lots of uncertainties there
for even for quite common materials like
hmx and tatb and so on
um and then we're going to try to
extract data in some meaningful form
from the measure scale simulations and
then we're going to construct these
ignition and growth rates uh from those
simulations so this is the data driven
approach that we're going to take so
multi-scaling is necessary uh just to
kind of recap all of that uh
multi-scaling is necessary measure skill
phenomena play a very large role
particularly hotspot phenomena and we
have to somehow bring together this
hotspot phenomena into a burn model and
we are choosing the path of a data
driven burn model that is informed by
direct numerical simulations so that's
the overall trajectory here so
so essentially to kind of put that in a
broader context that applies to a wide
range of materials we are developing
data-driven structure property
performance linkages for heterogeneous
energetic materials
um and so that's that's the overarching
theme here
um so just to give a sense for how
in our particular case we are
approaching this and this is you know
not very uncommon this would be a
standard route for anybody pursuing this
activity
um so the structure part consists of uh
you know images that we might get of an
energetic material this is a
prestenergic material I'm showing here
but it could be a PBX a plastic bonded
explosive uh where you would have in in
the formulation you would have some kind
of binder and then you would have the
crystals and then you would have
porosity so there'd be three phases
there here we have two phases uh what
one would do is once given a particular
microstructure suppose we want to
predict the sensitivity of the material
that has this particular microstructure
we can you know extract by sampling this
microstructure or otherwise statistical
analysis we can obtain some idea of uh
you know what are what how to
characterize its morphology so we would
get some PDFs of you know void size
distributions uh or avoid other features
of the voids you know surface specific
surface area of the voids and so on and
so forth so that's that's the first
structural analysis part uh the second
part would be the property determination
so one would do you know direct
numerical simulations to extract
properties of the material for example
its sensitivity
and one would then take those
simulations and inform some DD models
and in our particular case we have
developed three different types of DD
models uh data driven I'll uh here uh
I'll try not to say data driven to too
often I'll just say DD
um and uh the three different types are
mass what we call what I call message
Park and missile
um they're all of course appropriately
and creatively named to uh to uh you
know
exercise or create creativity in this
project very limited exercise but
um those are those are our models uh I
will explain what message is uh what
park is I will leave out missile uh
missile is a model that we just recently
uh have sent out uh into the world as a
publication uh and that's still not
fully uh fully established so I'm going
to talk about missile uh sorry message
in park two different types of data
driven models then we take these data
driven models and feed it to macro scale
Hydro codes uh as the ignition of growth
reads and then we predict the
sensitivity so this structure here the
structure part the property part and the
performance part so that's those are the
three things and we have linked all of
these in a multi-scale framework uh
successfully in in two different uh
efforts so I'll summarize those two
efforts today
um Okay so
so uh just very briefly uh 10 000 foot
view message uh is uh is a data driven
model that employs gaussian random
process surrogate modeling techniques uh
and we developed this uh you know uh
probably the last five years or so and
I'll show some uh some capabilities of
that uh but I'm going to focus today
more on Park which is a deep learning
approach and spend a lot of time on on
this one uh missile is something that's
a semi-anetical data-driven approach
that we have recently come up with is
it's it's fast it's dirty uh it may not
be as physically uh you know
sophisticated or accurate as spark and
message but it does a very good job of
predicting energetic material
sensitivity so those are the three types
of models and out of all these three
models we extract the very same thing
which is the ignition growth rates uh in
in an IG model framework and then we can
put those into a macro scale code so the
primary goal of rdd modeling effort is
to bridge the measures what I call the
measure scale which is the
microstructure and the macro scale which
is the homogenized behave material and
and and provide the closure models for
the macro scale uh and so it's in this
structure property performance framework
uh we have
different packages that we have uh we
have so far constructed
um the overarching package that deals
with the structure part is called matter
IQ which is a python and pytorch uh
package
um and then we do all the simulations
and the mesoscale as well as macro scale
simulations within in-house code called
Scimitar 3D which is a Fortran 95 code
that is basically uh
our workhouse solver solver for lots of
problems uh so just to describe very
briefly in a couple of slides what
Scimitar 3D is so symmetra 3D Scimitar
3D stands for solver for computing
immersed moving interfaces and transport
with adaptive refinement in 3D and these
were you know Publications that our
group put out you know as for the last
decade or so uh various kinds of
problems solved with Scimitar 3D uh just
to show a variety of of things that we
have done so we've done problems of high
speed impact you know computation of on
real geometries
microstructures and so on damage
mechanics poor collapse of course
three-dimensional and two-dimensional
sport collapse in hmx and other
materials
fragmentation impact and fragmentation
and blast wave interaction with
particles so compressible multi-materal
multi-phase flows is what Scimitar 3D is
capable of doing
it is a Cartesian grid fixed Cartesian
grid eulating sharp interface solver
which means that all the all the
interfaces you see here between
materials is treated sharply and tracked
very much similar to front tracking but
using level sets so it's a level set
based technique so what you see here for
example are zero level sets of the plate
and an impactor and so we track
explicitly the level sets so it's a
level set based interface and it's got
adaptive local refinement to get
features that are very fine
and it's paralyzed and uses image
processing to process microstructures so
we can go directly from an image to a
full-blown calculation on a fixed mesh
using you know Scimitar 3D so everything
everything on the mesh is described in
the form of level sets okay so uh so
that's the solver and we're going to use
that I'm going to not talk about the
solver anymore uh because that's what
we're going to use for all our
simulations
so the first approach for the DD
modeling is
um message and uh this was this paper
came out in 2018 and we've used this for
many many things since then
um and in the in the message approach
what we do is we Bridge the scales
between the measure scale that is the
microstructure and the macro skill to
get the performance uh simulation we
Bridge it using single core collapse
simulations
so this is important as a distinction uh
these single poor collapse simulations
are very fast you can do hundreds of
them in a couple of days and then you
can collect the data from the single
port simulations and what we do is we do
we get this uh hypersurface or a
surrogate model for the ignition and
growth rates of these single pores as a
function of the shock pressure the shock
pulse width the um porosity the diameter
of the voids or the or the size and
shape of the voids these three
parameters are size and shape of the
voids and then we get a surrogate model
and the surrogate model is used to close
the macro scale simulation so that's
that's message uh and so just to show an
example of how message works the
workflow of it uh suppose we have
microstructures and these were provided
to us by afrl Eglin
um from Eric Wally and Chris Molex group
uh so we we have these pressed hmx
microstructures we know their porosity
uh and and we know uh the size of it we
can take these microstructures uh and we
can analyze them uh to obtain things
like the probability density functions
of the Void size uh the aspect ratio of
the voids and the orientation of the
voids in the middle uh voids are the
main features here that we're interested
in it's a pressed metal there's no
binder and so then we can take the
statistics of the morphology and then we
also that's the structure part in the
property part what we do is we construct
these hyper surfaces for the ignition
and growth rates in in the space spanned
by the shock pressure and the void
diameter so we're doing single void
simulations we are varying diameters of
the Void we're varying the shock
pressures and we're collecting data and
we use the what's called Dynamic
creaking which is a kind of grp approach
goes in random process approach to
construct these hyper surfaces so these
hypersurfaces tell us about the
mesoscale sensitivity of the vector that
is you know if you if you subject one
pore to the given pressure of and the
pores of a certain size what is the
ignition and growth rate of hot spots
from that one pore so somehow we have to
take this information and convey to the
macro scale to get the performance
aspect of it
uh so this is just a brief uh picture of
how we populate the parameter space
which is the pressure and diameter of
the Void we do numerical simulations
here and these are adaptively done
um where uh there's an active learning
process that is in the grp and that it
indicates where we need more data so we
then follow that and do these
simulations and then we have an you know
measure rmse of uh to determine uh the
convergence of the surrogate in the
hyper hyper surface uh and so then we
say okay now we have a hypersurface that
we can use for for our um for our
calculations at the macro scale uh now
so these are again based on the single
poor data we we do the four collapse
reactive four collapse calculations uh
we collect data on the void collapse in
a void area The Hot Spot temperature The
Hot Spot area and mass of mass fraction
of reactant material that comes out of
one pore and using that data we extract
these these quantities the F dot
ignition and F dot growth and these are
taken simply from the data uh and we we
calculate the slopes of these uh these
this curve which is the mass fraction
reacted uh and from that from that curve
we determine the F dot ignition which is
the rate of ignition due to due to a
particular hotspot and then we also get
the rate of growth when it settles down
into the growth phase so initially when
the pore collapses you form this
ignition
um it ignites the material around it and
so that's the ignition phase between one
and two and then that ignited hotspot if
it survives it if it is critical it will
grow and then then we take between uh
when it's in the steady state growth
phase we take the growth rate so that's
how we get the F dot ignition F dot
growth once we have
growth then in order to close the macro
scale simulation all we have to do is
multiply that F dot ignition growth by
the porosity of the material and then we
get what macro scale requires which is
the Lambda dot ignition and Lambda node
growth and again those are exactly mean
exactly the same things as in Star Wars
ignition and growth model so we kind of
plugged into the ignition growth
modeling framework essentially
okay so uh then what we do is using uh
that information of the surrogate we
evaluate the performance and that is
done as follows uh so we do you know in
a coupon one dimensional calculations of
uh shock propagation of a particular
pressure and pulse width and once we
propagate the shock through the
homogenized macro scale maternal uh we
need this information of the landed
Lambda dot ignition and growth just like
in any ignition and growth model and
what we do is we get that from the
hypersurfaces uh so for a particular
point if we know the pressure there we
can go in and we know the microstructure
that is the void size and and all that
we can go and interrogate the the data
from the hyper surfaces and then that
gives us the uh heat release rate in
that particular cell and so we put that
into a macro scale and we look at you
know what happens to the shock and if
the shock Rises to the phone number
impression then we say okay that that's
critical right and so that's how we
construct these this James curve so here
I'm showing
using message the method I just
described which is uh based on the
surrogate modeling I'm I'm showing a
comparison between experiment the black
line is experiments done at Eglin Air
Force Base for hmx a particular
microstructure of hmx which is class 5
and so we know you know very well
characterized microstructure and we use
uh message which is the red line here to
calculate the James curve that is the
sensitivity curve and as you can see you
know the message does a fairly good job
of
construct of matching experiment uh in
terms of the sensitivity of the material
so the red line is message the pink the
purple line is Park and I will I will
show uh how that works in a second
uh so basically our objective is to get
this ecritical the energy the critical
energy for detonation and so that's the
data that
um that best fits this particular
experimental curve and our critical
energy is very very is a good agreement
with the experiment using message so we
can successfully now telescope the
microstructural information
and predict the sensitivity of of a
metal as a function of its
microstructure we have done other other
microstructures as well with success
um yeah and that that again was provided
to us by afrl there are a whole other
lots of other things we've done with the
surrogate based modeling we've done
inverse modeling that is once if you
know the if you know the criticality Can
we determine material properties we've
done that recently and that's worked out
uh in quite interesting ways
um and we're also doing transfer
learning so if we know something about h
of x
can we say something about RDX and and
that work is is ongoing in an NSF
project on meta learning uh so it's been
quite successful the message route has
been quite successful
so the second route of data driven
modeling that we've been pursuing uh in
our muri project
excuse me uh it's called Park
uh Park stands for physics aware
recurrent convolution this is a paper a
couple of two or three papers that have
come out recently with Steve Beck
um group
um and this one came out in science
advances this year
um and uh so I will briefly discuss what
what park stands for
so park is part of a larger effort
um that is um part of a package that we
are working on called matter IQ
which is an AI based toolkit for
materials by Design so park fits into
that as as the DD model
um and it's worked jointly of course
with Steve and and Fung uh and and we
are just to give you a very broad idea
of what metal IQ is all about so in
matter IQ
uh which is again for mentors but design
what we're trying to do is we are uh we
have different components to the package
the first one is a synthetic synthetic
microstructure generator because we
don't have a large number of
microstructural samples we want to take
in archetypal samples that maybe you
have one image for but then generate uh
you know a non-sample of sample so we
can do statistical modeling of it
um and and then we can actually do DNS
simulations on that Ensemble so that's
the synthetic microstructure part then
we have machine learning models for
various purposes and I'll highlight some
of them
um in in the following uh segment uh and
then we have actor critic design
optimizers so we can optimize
microstructures uh based on their
performance characteristics and then we
we connect everything because we have
Fortran modules for for the solvers
there's Legacy modules and then we have
all the python and pytorch we have
wrappers that connect all of these into
an actual design tool
so so that's the framework in which Park
sits as the DD platform
uh so in so the matter IQ DD platform is
uh in terms of the structure it's a deep
learning based approach for generating
and experimenting with synthetic
microstructures so we can change
microstructures in various ways uh to
conduct these experiments and I'll
describe how that works
um and then we do simulations and the
simulations uh then feed into a deep
learning based approach to predict
mesoscale Dynamics and then that then
feeds into the macro scale performance
evaluation so this Loop is basically
closed by Park
um so let me talk a little bit about the
structure part and how DD Works into the
structure part uh here we can synthesize
microstructures using uh cnns and this
work has been published in a couple of
papers last
in the last few years starting from 2020
um so basically we use a gan approach
for synthesizing microstructures uh if
you're very broadly Gan is an
adversarial contest between uh What uh
generator Network and the discriminator
network where the generator tries to
deceive the discriminator by generating
uh samples of microstructures in the
discriminator then being the
discriminator
um you know attempts to push the
generator closer and closer to the
Target image by by minimizing an error
between the two between the candidate
microstructure and the Target
microstructure and eventually you know
through this process they converge to a
particular
um hopefully to the Target
microstructure or facsimile is thereof
so that's the that's the strategy and
it's in the paper by Chun at all in 2020
um and basically the what we have shown
in that paper is that we can take one
snapshot of an energetic material
microstructure and generate uh many many
uh similar
microstructure with similar
characteristics so then we can do
numerical experiments on them uh so
these are some ground truth samples of
microstructures that we obtained uh from
from afrl the middle row is a transfer
learning based approach uh and results
from that and the lower row is the Gan
final Gan approach that we settled on as
you can see the Gan approach gives nice
clean microstructures the transfer
learning approach can have some local
glitches these are close-ups of parts of
this microstructure and we found the Gan
actually produces nice crisp
microstructures that emulate the the the
real microstructure and we also done in
that paper we show quantitative
comparisons of various statistics of
these microstructures uh showing that
the black line here is ground truth
um and these are probability densities
of the Void size aspect ratio and
orientation of the voids and we show
that you know our the Gan approach
produces real microstructures with
quantitative similarity as well so you
know we're capturing the the
characteristics of the real
microstructure and this can also be
extended to three dimensions the the
paper also addresses 3D microstructures
or in this particular case of sandstone
uh where you can take the you know
ground truth Sandstone
um microstructure and synthesize it and
generate ensembles of synthesized
microstructures and these are showing 2D
slices of these microstructures and
quantitative comparisons uh there is
very dense I would go into it but you
can look at where various metrics of the
quantitative characteristics of the real
microstructure and the synthesized and
we show that you know the synthesized
microstructures capture the
characteristics of the of the real
microstructures fairly back
so that's that's the structure
generation part now what what that
allows us to do in a materials by Design
standpoint is that we can manipulate the
microstructure so once we have the
Baseline microstructure that that
emulates the real microstructure then uh
we can can turn knobs uh literally in in
the generator uh basically we are
modulating the latent variables and by
modulating related variables we can
change the structure of the metal so for
example uh just to show one one instance
uh by performing a particular operation
here we go from this initial small
microstruct more small grain size
microstructure and we can manipulate the
like the um latent variables to go
towards uh larger finally to a larger
microstructure and we can do this in a
for various other things as well for
example here we can control the
orientation of the of the crystals or
the voids uh in fact we we have shown
that uh depending on the void
orientation the sensitivity of the
material can change massively um uh
avoids the oriented along the shock
propagation Direction uh tend to be more
sensitive than voids that are oriented
normal to the propagation so we can
actually investigate effects of
orientation of of voids and so on and so
we can now you know manipulate the
microstructures virtually to to get
different void void orientations we can
also look at mixtures of sizes by
modulating the latent variables the this
uniformity when you if we toggle the
latent variables in a certain way we get
bimodal mixtures and so on and support
so we can now control the
microstructures virtually
um and these are done you know these are
a picture of the latent variable uh
weights here
um and by for different weights of the
of the latent variables we can uh we get
different Crystal sizes void sizes and
so this allows for flexibility in making
different microstructures
um we can also paint microstructures
using this approach which is uh to say
that we can spatially vary the
microstructure so this is uh my
microstructure that was generated with
small grains on one end and large grades
on the other end so we can do that uh we
can also paint uh microstructural
um the regions so here we have taken the
Hawkeye which is uh the University of
Iowa symbol
um and we've gotten permission to do
that from our uh from our University
which is very important uh and what we
show here is that we want to put large
crystals in this yellow region and and
small crystals in the black region so we
implemented we imprinted that Hawkeye
image in onto this microstructure if you
can see here these are the large
crystals and then the surroundings of
small crystals and we actually uh 3D
printed this uh we have a depth score
Grant with a collaborator Professor Sean
song
um and and he does he does pressure jet
Printing and so this is sugar crystals
of course being a university that's we
can only handle sugar
um and so you know here you can see that
you know there's a uh the the Hawkeyes
larger crystals are printed over here
and these are all small crystals tools
and that's zooming into the this region
here you can see the large crystals of
the Hawkeye symbol so uh so we can
actually transmit our microstructures to
uh somebody who does 3D printing and
actually do that and then of course
finally we we use these microstructures
the synthetic ones
um and look at uh you know the the
response shock response of it in
simulation so this is for small crystals
and it's for large crystals and you can
see the growth rate of hot spots is very
different uh in the two of them so
that's that's the uh facility now we're
also doing other things um Irene Fung
who's actually at Livermore for the
summer
um Irene is working on manipulating
microstructures to explore design uh in
the following way that she's
um
actually
um if she can actually modulate damage
on the microstructure so she's coming up
with a deep learning approach so that we
can take a input microstructure and we
can actually remove all the damage from
in there and then re-damage it in a
controlled way so that we can insert as
you know as much damage as we want
because we want to study the effect of
of damaged microstructures on their
sensitivity so that's the idea over
there
okay so uh in fact I will actually in
the interest of time skip through
Irene's work because I want to get to
park I think I'm I'm actually
how much time do I have
um maybe five to ten minutes let's say
let's say 10 minutes yeah okay I might
take 10 then because I I okay so so in
park basically what park does is that it
uh it learns from DNS simulations and
then it can actually do predictions uh
once it's learned from it uh so you know
we we are asking questions like can can
we train an AI model to assimilate the
physics of energy localization can an
air model serve as a surrogate for DNS
calculations uh and can AI models
provide physical insights so we don't
want it to be a black box we want
interpretability so we want to get
information out of out of park
um and as I said Park fits into this uh
this overall framework where as a data
driven modeling uh uh entity so we this
is the DDS DD model that we're using uh
in in the larger materials design
optimization and Discovery framework of
matter IQ
um so park basically the the idea behind
Park is that we are going to formulate
the shock India's hotspot Evolution as a
dynamical system uh that is we we picked
this variable x uh from the physics of
the problem and in our particular case
we pick X to be a function basically
consists of a vector of the temperature
of the hot spots the pressure in the in
the domain and the microstructure
because microstructure evolves so it
goes from becoming from Voyage to void
collapse and then eventually to become
hot spots so we want to uh you track the
evolution of all three things the
temperature the pressure and the
microstructure and so we train the model
to learn those 3 three aspects the
evolution of those three aspects from
numerical simulations
um and that's the the idea behind Park
so basically Park is assimilates
knowledge of how that evolution of this
field uh X takes place
um and uh
and we formulated as a recurrent neural
network where we uh have differentiator
in integrator
networks and these differentiator and
integrated networks uh assimilate the
derivatives of the variable X and then
they perform the integration and it the
time the time evolution is is
assimilated within Park uh to eventually
predict what happens at the end when the
hot spots finally
um grow and merge in the material so
just to show an example of of Park
calculation so this is the top row is
DNS for this microstructure this is the
park prediction for that microstructure
after training so
um so you can see that sorry
um so park does a good job of of
predicting what happens the hotspot uh
the location of the hot spot the the
frequency of the hot spots and so on and
uh the advantage is that while a DNS
would take days on the HPC Park would be
would just be you know really quick
prediction uh so it predicts the time
evolution of hot spots
um and uh it also predicts the pressure
uh as you can see the pressure is not as
well predicted as the temperature
because the pressure has smaller
gradients than the temperature the
temperature is much sharper but it does
a fairly decent job of predicting the
pressure Evolution as well so this x
which is and the void collapse Evolution
the microstructure evolution so this is
a in a park exercised on many many
different microstructures the lefts are
ground truth and the rights are
predicted it's I know it's very
difficult to see this but basically the
overall message is uh you know Park
predictions are in good agreement and
this is a quantitative comparison so for
various microstructures the worked Park
and we've done DNS and the and the
confidence intervals here are the
microstructural variability due to
microstructure variability so this is
the hotspot temperature versus time the
hotspot area versus time as you can see
Park in the mean and also in in terms of
the distribution Park produces a good
hot spot area Evolution over time in
good agreement with the ground truth the
rate of change of area of the hot spot
versus time is also in good agreement
with the with the ground trip so we get
the hotspot Dynamics uh right now we've
used this part model to do the
multi-scale full multi-scale so
basically that came out in a paper uh in
pep actually just just just recently and
where we can take a macro scale image
sample we can do the statistical
analysis of it we do DNS simulations we
drain Park and then Park predicts the
the hotspot growth rate and so on and we
feed that to the macro scale simulation
and predict FDT and the and the
criticality envelope and this is the
James envelope of uh predicted by
message so message sorry park park is
the purple one message is the red one so
the two approaches uh somewhat in the in
the low pressure range as you can see
there is more sensitivity and they
straddle the experimental data while in
the high pressure range they do a
they're in very good agreement with each
other uh and also uh with experiment so
this is uh this is a you know a
demonstration that that we now can put
all of the pieces together in a
multi-scale framework
um now the question is of course did we
learn physics or is it just pictures
um and so can it tell us something in
order to investigate this we tested Park
in many many ways
um first we tested this to uh you know
off-the-shelf uh physics naive models
for for learning
um and we showed that Park does a better
job or you know in fact some of the
physics naive off-the-shelf uh codes
that we tried this on you know did not
match with the with the ground truth but
we are able to match closely with the
ground truth the second thing we tested
was looking at time Evolution Beyond
training that is we trained park for a
certain time and then we let power go
and then we do the DNS for those longer
times and see if it captures the
evolution correctly beyond the training
time which is an extrapolation and park
does that successfully
um then we also looked at outlier
microstructures we had trained Park on a
certain set of microstructures and then
we picked microstructures parts of the
microstructive that were were quite
quite different from what we had trained
Park on and we looked at whether it can
actually predict uh the you know the
behavior of those sensitivity of those
uh for example very very large Crystal
like that we do a DNS and then we also
look at Park and ask where the park can
predict where the hot spots are
um we also tested Park to unseen loading
conditions that is we train Park on a
certain set of pressures and we looked
at other pressures uh and there as well
Park uh captures the physics and and
gives us the hot spot correct hotspot
growth rates uh so and aside from this
we also asked the question can park tell
us some information about the physics so
in order to do this uh we asked the
question uh from our simulation we noted
that only a small subset of voids
generate hot spots and why is that what
is particularly interesting about those
critical uh voids and can we get
information about this so we used the
saliency map which is a derivative of
the temperature with respect to the
microstructure and we have these two
Fields the temperature field and the
microstructure field so we can then
establish this the sensitivity Matrix
and that is uh what I'm calling the
saliency map field and so if we
threshold the saliency map field we we
find that there are the saliency map
tells us which voids went critical and
formed hot spots uh and so we can
superpose this on the microstructure and
we can examine these voids that cause
the hot spots as you can see the the
vast majority of voids fail to produce
hot spots so then we're asking what is
special about these critical hot spots
uh and we zoom in there and we try to
correlate that the morphology
information with the sensitivity
information
and what we find is
you know by doing this analysis uh is
the following and it's actually you know
we it matches with with the physics that
we had earlier learned in in various uh
other works uh which is that this is
that this is the critical voyage and
this is a non-critical voice and as you
can see the critical voids don't look
terribly different from the non-critical
worlds
um you know but there are subtle
differences and there's subtle
differences are as follows
um so if you look at the average void
diameter of critical voids they tend to
be smaller than the average diameter of
the non-critical voids uh if you look at
the aspect ratio of the critical voids
versus non-critical voice as the
elongatedness they're not terribly
different uh but if you look at the
orientation it has a very strong effect
so critical voids are nearly horizontal
with respect to the uh sorry neither
horizontal with respect to
um
the shop Direction whereas uh the
non-critical voids are oriented much
more you know parallel to the shock
Direction so that orientation has a
significant impact on sensitivity
Okay so
um I think I can summarize this now so
basically Park can predict well
um the response and and we we used about
35 DNS simulations so the data is not
terribly large uh and park manages to
gather information from that uh and and
we showed that Park does produce
physically
um meaningful and physically insightful
results that we can interrogate
um and so I I think there are further
developments of Park that I will not go
into right now we are working on
improving accuracy for weak hot spots uh
and and and
uh and other other accuracy issues and
robustness issues
um but so let me summarize uh finish by
uh putting the slide on matter IQ so
basically we now uh have a the ability
to manipulate structures uh we can do
simulations that feed into Data driven
models and we can predict the macro
scale phenomena of sensitivity in a
multi-scale setting
so I'll finish that thank you thank you
so much for the wonderful talk today
um let's have a q a session I don't see
any question in chat room so um if you
anyone has questions please unmute
yourself and ask
um I don't know if you can base your
hands
um or unmute yourself and just speak
either way
anyone
Larry yeah yeah
um
I was wondering um had you looked at uh
applying your Technique to samples of
varying initial density where you might
have porous materials versus very dense
materials
uh yes uh Larry thanks for the question
I
um we did two microstructures uh you
know we we don't have access to too many
uh samples we did and our 10
microstructure and um
and
um a classify microstructure both
pressed hmx
um and our predictions of sensitivity
were
were in accord with experiments on those
two microstructures both done at afrl
Eglin we are actually working on a third
now we are doing PB access and we're
working on a third microstructure as
well which is very different from those
two microstructures so the porosity is
much lower so we are doing that right
now
yeah very very impressive work thank you
very much
thank you Larry uh just to add uh
clarification that the r10 had a seven
percent porosity and the class five had
a 14 14 porosity so quite different
microstructures okay thank you thank you
okay we have a another question in chat
room by Cooper we ask did you look at
the difference in the surface area for
the critical versus non-critical voice
surface area
um
[Music]
no uh so this so we looked at diameter
aspect ratio right so aspect ratio is
not terribly sensitive to the aspect
ratio it is sensitive to the diameter so
the surface area does matter and in fact
this is you know common common knowledge
and surface specific surface area does
matter so the smaller voids tend to be
uh more sensitive than the larger voids
for a given aspect ratio so that's you
know that's our
our finding
foreign
for a given porosity then that means
that there will be a larger surface area
specific surface area with smaller
points
so that's a specific surface area is
important
okay
and it's consistent with both Park
findings as well as message bindings
thank you
you had a curve you know the results of
the masses and results of the the curve
from the park one is underestimating the
other one is overestimating
um
in physics point of view or application
point of view if it fits is more
valuable it's underestimating it's
better or overestimating it's better in
criticality
well I I I think having neither would be
better best I guess but
um
I know I sort of have it in so let me
actually uh again oh yes you're
mentioning this one right yeah yeah
um previous one
yeah that one yeah this one yeah um for
some reason uh hang on one second
and push that up okay yeah so this this
region is the most difficult part so you
know this one is actually fairly
straightforward to predict which you
know is is heartening that we can do
that but but I would I would rather have
good predictions over here uh the
problem over here is and we're working
on this is that over here it's not truly
hydrodynamic the void collapse here so
this there is a there is also physics
missing I think at this in this area of
the plot
um because as you approach about five
GPA and so on you can get
um effects of Shear bands and other
strength related uh aspects of the
material
um and those are not terribly well
modeled currently in our work
um and we are trying to remedy that uh
by by using better physical models for
this to represent the strength and we
made some progress on that so that's
ongoing work
um but I think so I would in in in
answering your question young so I I
don't know if this is particularly
um issue with the more the DD models
themselves or is it actually a
misrepresentation of the physics there
until we fix the physics I would not
know what say about those two things
you know okay
yeah
yeah looks like if you average those two
then you're being good shape
the blue day this is I've got a couple
of questions
yeah
um in regards to park I didn't see a
void void interaction
uh term or
uh a is some kind of provision for void
void interaction uh what what role do
you believe
that plays and what determines a
critical defect morphology size
orientation
um
the boy in my in my estimation the void
void interaction part is inherently
learned by Park
um
whereas in the message model we have to
have another surrogate model which we
have and we have to insert it into
message which we have done in order to
get these curves so in message we have
to make an effort to include worldwide
interaction because it relies on single
word calculations whereas because Park
relies on a full DNS and the full DNS
already has the Whiteboard interactions
in it I think Park actually takes that
into account
um now
having said that we've done recent work
that shows that for white small white
sizes by which I mean about a one micron
diameter void sizes
um worldwide interactions may not be a
terribly strong effect
um for larger void diameters we find
wide wide interactions a very strong
effect so I think in this instance
because the void size is in class 5
center around about 0.5 Micron
um I don't know if the void size
interactions will play a major role in
in this you know in the discrepancies
that exist in the predicted predictions
for this particular case
um but I think Park actually should take
into account void wide interactions
yeah of course you have the ignition and
ignition criticality and then the growth
and you know there are opportunities in
both phases to be able to take place
um uh but uh yeah I mean I think that it
yeah it seems like
some kind of provision for part going
for that considers the that possibility
but clearly uh having the first you know
as a first order the you know the void
itself is is probably one of the
I guess like you're saying the most one
of the most important things
um yeah in regards to the low pressure
regime that you're pointing to
um do you believe that there are
fundamental mechanism changes
um it seems like you're implying that by
saying over a certain pressure regime
it's hydrodynamic and you know under
that could be you know more of a uh
viscous and other kinds of
interactions that perhaps we don't
normally encounter whether it be surface
physics or
other kinds of modes or what have you
right have any thoughts about that
specifically mechanism changes yes yes I
certainly do actually uh so if you look
at you know where where we are about
five GPA find GPA is about the about the
um pressure at which we find that most
the voids are sort of borderline they're
about they're not collapsing in in full
hydrodynamic mode and if we do the
calculations of that in fact with the
Johnson cook Model the rate dependent
model and so on
um that you guys actually uh have
published on
um we find that you know there are there
are Shear bands and there are there is a
significant change of mode of collapse
of the Void from uh whereas for high
pressures it's hydrodynamic you know in
the jetting mode for the lower pressures
it tends to be more of a closure mode in
fact as you go to lower pressures it
closes with the sideways pinching mode
rather than a jet mode and in the
sideways pinching mode shock the shear
bands play a very large role so I think
there is there is definitely some kind
of a mechanism transition because below
below about you know 5 GPA or so
um you know you you really don't get
criticality so
you know the void May collapse but it
collapses so weekly that you don't get
criticality
um so there is there is something here
happening both in terms of
well first of all in terms of the mode
of collapse and the strength of the
material kind of playing a role but
secondly also
I think this this region is much more
sensitive to the
Ms chemical kinetics models and we've
done quite a bit of examination of that
um which can you know this curve that
I'm showing even for message can move
all the way out here with the low you
know with the chemist one chemistry
model reaction chemistry model and all
the way to the other side with another
chemistry model and we found that in
fact doing an inverse analysis is the
best fit to the experimental data from
the chemistry models comes from uh you
know the Henson one equation
Global kinetics model so so that also
plays a role clearly that the chemical
kinetics because the temperature is here
due to void collapse at lower pressures
tend to be borderline so if you if you
it's very so the reaction kinetics model
is very sensitive uh in that region and
predicting the criticality so there's a
lot going on in that region that really
needs a lot of looking into and that's
actually the interesting region for us
because you know that's the threshold
and if we can't predict that correctly
then you know that that that's not a
terribly great model so so this
variation here is of concern but I would
I would first
try to get the physics right before
trying to um you know figure out which
DD model is is better in that sense
so there's a lot going on there much
work to be done in that region thank you
and great great talk
thanks Gil
any other questions from audience
well I'm I have a rather a comments than
uh questions about the naming physics
aware
you know there are a lot of active
research going on in
physics simulation and um and also you
know the machine learning side one
example is physics informed General
Network and another one is more
traditional way of bringing the physics
into the data model is using the
projection based physics to reduce
certain model
it's it's clear that why they are
calling their data driven method is
physics aware of physics informed
because they actually using underlying
company equations to build a data driven
model but but your Park Model I don't
see that
and I do I do see that data is generated
from DNS model which is you know solving
the physics governing equations but in
data driven it's the physics model is
not directly integrated
into the into the model so
yeah there is a something
debatable here
whether you can call it physics aware I
know that you have shown that you know
generalizability at the end you know
your Park Model actually you know
predicts some physical characteristics
right
um some some ratio the rate
but still I don't see where the physics
is Incorporated in the process of
building the model itself
so so yes so you know this has come up
uh quite frequently uh especially with
the PIN
the pin framework and so on so clearly
in pin there are you know there are
um in particular the Divergence free
velocity constraint is built into the
network right
um
not only that actual governing equations
they are operating into the electric
remote you're not absolutely so in in
some sense we are much more uh or
somewhere we're in between that
part that uh philosophy of of making the
network emulate the full governing
equations and the reduced order modeling
um in the sense that
we are trying to learn because it is
intended to be a bridge between the meso
and macro scale simulations we are
abstracting from the mesoscale what is
physically relevant to the macro scale
in our particular case what is
physically relevant is the temperature
view the pressure field and the
microstructural evolution
um
you know the system of equations we are
solving is very very large it is a
reactive fully compressible system with
interfaces in full interfacial Dynamics
you know we we don't want to be in the
situation where we
impose upon the network
the need to solve that entire system of
equations where that's not the idea here
the idea is to use some
of our expert intuition in picking the
physics that needs to be learned by the
network and we couple those three
elements the temperature the pressure
and the microstructure within the vector
X and so we are trying to look at the
coupling of the physics between the
shock
and the hot spot and the void and in
that sense we are keying in what is
required in terms of physical
ingredients into the network uh and
we're making it actually emulate the
the evolution of the process through the
differential equations
so
you know it
if we don't do that we don't get the
results for the hotspot Evolution that
as I've shown we don't get the correct
results so
and and there you know the other tests I
showed that we are actually capturing
physics and we're making you know uh
extracting insights that are physically
meaningful uh and match with expert
knowledge
um I think in those senses
you know what what we have is a
physically aware system
um
you know it's not it's not physical
physics is not the same as a physics
informed neural networks and it's not
the philosophy the philosophy it's not a
reduced order model it's it's
using physics and physical knowledge and
integrating that into a neural network
that produces for us what we need which
is taking the information from the
measure scale and transmitting it to the
macro scale
um so that's that's my that's my overall
kind of outlook on what we are trying to
do okay okay over there
um
is it is there any other questions
well well I mean we actually passed the
10 minutes
um to study no no no no sorry I mean it
means you know we are very interested in
your work so I think it's a good time to
wrap up well let's thank our speaker
today for the wonderful talk and uh
wonderful q a sessions
um a lot of Applause yeah
and yeah I mean let's wrap up here thank
you everyone
and if you do have a question please
email Uday
um directly I'm sure who they is going
to answer your questions
um you know division three yes well and
then yeah and and and then you know of
course the future collaborations uh
between Lawrence Livermore and and then
yogurt and I think it's it's already
going on so let's continue to do so
thank you
so much thank you guys
bye-bye